foreign
[Music]
North Korea is now really deeply vested
in being a nuclear weapon state they
need to get those nuclear weapons to
their targets they need to test on a
regular basis right I mean they want to
have a full-blown program here right and
it is actually full-blown I really do
want to have like a full spectrum
nuclear program
[Music]
testing a lot this year my guess would
be the reason for that is because for a
couple years there when Trump was
President there was a sense that maybe
there might be a breakthrough and Trump
was meeting them and so they kind of put
all that stuff on hold because it looked
like they might get a deal ultimately
that fell through
[Music]
foreign
I would argue that North Korea is
basically a gangster State North Korea
is sort of like what would happen if
like The Godfather like the Corleone
family from The Godfather managed to
take over a whole country
[Music]
both have said that they expect in this
calendar year uh seventh North Korean
nuclear test we anticipate that any next
North Korean nuclear test will be even
more powerful than the one that came 4.